hi everybody thank you for watching this
review of the new tech TC one product my
name is Ron Vargas I'm not on sake oh hi
Allen we produce a show here in the San
Francisco Bay Area I personally have
been a professional technical director
using the new tech product since 2011
I've used all of the models of the 860
the 460 the mini the 8000 and as
mentioned we purchased the TC one about
a year ago doing this review kind of
shoots my I shoot myself in the foot
because I'm friendly with people that
sell the product I'm friendly with
people that rent the product and I'm
friendly with production houses that use
this product professionally so it's not
gonna do me any good by keeping it real
for anybody interested in purchasing the
TC one I understand there's a special
that new tech is running where you trade
in your old new tech and get up to
seventy five hundred dollars if you
trade it in for a TC one and I just want
to be clear about the new tech product
all of the products in theory it's a
wonderful product it says it does so
much and they have big props to new tech
on their marketing department they're
selling these NewTek TriCaster x'
however in practice everything that it
says it does it really can't do on a
professional level if we have the budget
we're gonna have to use a separate
component to encode the live stream
we're gonna have to use a separate
component to record wherever we can use
a backup component we get we can't use
everything that the TriCaster says it
can do for primary we we definitely need
backup to do this if you're looking to
get into a video production as a hobby
then maybe you can get the
new tech products because it's a toy but
if you're gonna buy it professionally
wear anything really matters if you're
gonna be hired out to use this product
at its fullest capacity it's not going
to deliver the most recent event that
the TC one was hired to do was the Maker
Faire Bay Area festival in here in the
Bay Area and I was hired to use it
specifically for its MDI capacity and we
had all four SDI inputs being used and
we used six NDI sources using the new
tech spark the problem that we
encountered using this was processing it
seemed like the TriCaster was too taxed
a little bit too much to handle what we
were doing granted we weren't using the
built-in encoder which can deliver to
two or more content delivery networks in
theory but we've ran into problems
throughout the year that we use this
with with that concern but we just do it
for our show simulation we're really not
using it to its fullest capacity when we
try to use it to its fullest capacity we
run into problems the NDI scan converter
which replaces the I VGA component where
you can see laptop or it just it doesn't
it's not dependable it works sometimes
in real time and other times it doesn't
but this has been the problem with all
of new tech products from the get-go
what it says it can do and what it
actually can deliver it's a little
misleading there are other there are
other video switches that you can buy I
strongly recommend the Blackmagic
components where you get separate
encoders separate recorders a separate
video switcher they just divide it all
up but this whole mobile truck in a box
theory that new tech sells itself on
don't be fooled
it's it's not that good even the new
tech cameras that work with the PTZ
controller in the new tech it's it's it
works marginal it's it's not it's not
exceptional you know you wanna you're
gonna get what you pay for for the most
part with the new tech camera as far as
the the new tech product itself you're
you're gonna pay a significant amount of
money but you're really not getting the
best component to use so we're using and
we're using the TC one right now a
simple recording we're not encode we're
not encoding we're not going live we we
trusted to do that but the more you want
to use the TriCaster for the less
dependable it's gonna be did I miss
anything Allen so Ron Vargas is a
preferred technical director here in the
Bay Area and he's been doing this the
latter mostly the latter part of his
life and I myself have been hosting the
show simulation that Ron produces in
directs and we have purchased this
TriCaster TC 1 so within my lifetime
I've only spent about a year and a half
using the try casters and aiming to use
there the connectivity of adding
additional cameras and doing this multi
camera livestream technology and some
some of the things that I can par par
mention along this review are that
initially when this purchase occurred
that I figured that by spending upwards
of forty thousand dollars on the
equipment that we were putting them
together that it would be like if you
bought a Tesla and that the Tesla was to
be able to adequately drive from
destination to destination with a
hundred percent accuracy but for some
reason sometimes with the new tech
technology and we understand that it's
hundreds of Engineers and that are
really trying to build this this
technology together and it's pretty good
but it would be like if the Tesla was to
occasionally malfunction in the middle
of the highway or the street and you
would have to
with the Tesla and then say oh okay now
I have to call in to support and I can't
even really call and I have to chat into
the support and then there's a really
strenuous process with that so you can
really understand if you're trying to
spend tens of thousands of dollars on
something like Tesla or a new TriCaster
they should be in almost a hundred
percent performance category just a
couple of the other things that we've
experienced of this technology when we
first Ron mentioned this when we first
bought the system we also bought new
Tech's NDI PTZ cameras and they to say
the least
they had a lag when we were switching
between cameras on their system and it
was a very noticeable lag and we had to
return those and get JVC PTZ cameras
instead because there is no lag with
those cameras and we are not using the
well we're not using them through the
TriCaster would just as I mentioned
earlier we're using a separate component
and as Alan had mentioned you know we
purchased this new tech NDI PTZ system
believing in its efficiency and I sold
Alan on this idea and I I definitely
retract everything I said as far as
purchasing this gear it didn't deliver
as it said it would so there's a couple
of one more another really pressing
thing is that basically from the time in
March of 2018
until what was it six months later maybe
even longer nine months later it took us
a really long time to be able to have
the audio and the video sync when we
livestream to Facebook and YouTube at
the same time so going to two content
delivery networks had we had an issue
with audio/video sync for six to nine
months in 2018 until finally we were
able to work and it was it was a very
strenuous process working with their
team trying to figure out what the
issues were working with the person that
sold us the TriCaster as well and I just
don't wish that process to any content
I wish for a content creator that wants
to buy something like a black magic or
more new tech system like Ron said the
older systems have had a greater amounts
of efficacy and the issues that ron has
Ron's bringing up with what happened at
the Maker Faire it's not just happen at
just the Maker Faire it's been happening
at several of the technical the higher
end technical events that ron has went
and went and produced using the
TriCaster in its fullest capacity any
events where we use the TriCaster
minimally as mentioned and just get
separate components it works fine so we
we get that it's it's a hundreds of
people that are trying to engineer this
technology it's like trying to engineer
a Boeing 747 or like I said a Tesla like
it requires big teams of people that are
working their asses off but at the same
time just don't mark it that the NDI PTZ
cameras are so X exceptional the most
complete production on the planet is
that what they say yeah in theory but in
practice no so let's wrap it up here
that's enough we are would have loved to
have all the components here working to
its fullest if we have the time and the
patience however we don't so wrapping it
up if you want to buy the new tech
product if you're going to use it as a
hobby go right ahead and work with them
as they are a beta test their products
but if you're going to purchase it for a
professional capacity look into other
products thank you for watching thank
you everyone
good luck